regardez sont tous avec des ballons
c'est très simple ils vont devoir faire
un parcours avec des ballons ils vont
devoir faire va mettre trente secondes
pour faire le parcours sans s'en péter
un ballon d'accord on va démarrer avec
kelly et j'arrive je viens nous
rejoindre si vous y arrivez
celui qui arrive à péter aucun ballon
repartira avec un magnifique cadeau
d'accord allez-y les cieux et regarder
la pète menn ps même paix va le faire
hein je vous le dis tout de suite et à
gaston lagarde que vous pouvez voir
voilà qu'elle a un gaston lagaffe au
plus magnifique
attention c'est parti on va démarrer
avec on va démarrer avec bones slovaquie
à dorval et mike kelly cha kelly a dit
kelly est ce que tes pages arrive
le monde
[Applaudissements]
et la fin mais au fait tu attends tu
m'as hotu rau
[Musique]
mais vite à 38,21 ce temps les pompiers
sont en colère
simple et navid et qu'il y attention aux
branches est né avec maxime galy
c'est parti vite faut pas que tu
prétends ballon mais attention
ouais ouais ouais
oui oui alexis elbaz et bathie seras tu
là dessus vas-y maxime robin maxime
c'est terminé
là-bas match de leur vie
beat les fais attention tu vas te
laisser quelque chose
pas mal pas mal ait ans avec le cactus
quand on est sain déjà atteint il a
perdu un ballon mais ne l'a pas il n'a
pas prêté attention
il n'a pas combien de ballons vas-y
vas-y s'attendre à pire que des faits
l'armée arrêts parmi ces terminaux dont
matthieu delormeau c'était à venir et
chercher en rester là bas à rester
là-bas attention on va enchaîner on va
chez rivages de fausses vasselle et
isabelle morini bosc
alors on va demander une minute pour
isabelle une minute
merci tu repasses sûr on passerait tout
à l'heure drogba elle est connue est
premier truc qu'elle elle se plante à
mazsalaca stade a dit button
une vue du dessus c'est beau ça s'est
terminé merci valeur de cheria fais rien
fait la merci à gâteau proulx agathe
vas-y alors agathe on va demander dix
minutes 1 et marc comme ça bah voila
merci à les bouder
vous dire je le sens bien j'ai boudé la
moder tu passe en dessous qu'il est con
c'est terminé s'est terminée bouder
secteur milly jean bernet et calme calme
oui
c'est terminé attention vous avez vous
syfy attention attention attention alors
allez-y basse pas
oui c'est bien ça
oui c'est bien jean mi
les bases y aller on a droit de péter de
ballon arrêté arrêté que ces ballons oui
pour l'instant ces matches au japon mais
c'est pas possible
maxime pas mal mais pour l'instant c'est
mathieu oui si tu peux je vais demander
à gaston lagaffe et paddy gastaud m'a
dit attention c'est gaston lagaffe ses
pairs vous êtes gaston s'est perdue il
s'est perdu bec ta cascadeur attention
pas de phase i sur va être papa de
mekhissi faire attention papa là tu en
fais tu refais genre c'est bon
maintenant c'est bon banide a droit à
les bâtisses et bon allez vas-y vas-y
paye c'est bon ça passe ça passe ça
passe ça passe mais bref c'est un
servile et il est fabuleux attendant
c'est ça le plus dur ça doit depuis la
droite péter de ballons il a droit de
péter de ballons
bravo mon père thiriat et un ballon ça
passe j'ai fini tu dis quand même allez
c'est fini
oui c'est magique
basile beau père ouais ouais ouais ouais
c'est pas ça c'est gagné hu
les crs la de village
est ce que vous voulez que pour un arc à
moi je dois dire bravo paix pour mon
frère je savais que j'allais réussir